et pour en parler nous sommes avec eux
jean-luc mail à millas ancien député
européen aujourd'hui que bennahmias
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors on le disait les
trois priorités affichées d'ursula von
der leyen le pacte vers la révolution
numérique et la géopolitique on va y
revenir
mais avant un autre dossier chaud on
vient d'entendre la politique migratoire
l europe selon vous prend elle le
dossier suffisamment à bras le corps au
delà de la gestion de l'urgence
je dirais qu'il prétend vraiment temps
alors je fais que de dire que le
règlement dublin ii qui a tout la route
tout le monde le sait c'est la grecque
qui ont entraîné le prix d'italie kahn a
payé le prix
on al issa après sur le dos de la
turquie en personne les accords
totalement stupide avec la turquie pour
accueillir les migrants qui arrivent
elles notamment de syrie est aussi du
liban et du reste du moyen-orient et de
l'afrique
tout ça me tenait tout la route ok c'est
une alors après j'ai entendu madame
devant deux meilleurs ennemis on va
faire on va tout changer alors elle
demande du plat très bien donc c'est
tout le pays où arrive le migrant qui
devra tout gérer ses deux salles cas
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
alors non il faut penser maintenant la
difficulté si vous voulez c'est que onze
qui a un accord des 27 pays européens
pour accueillir des migrants
malheureusement la réponse est non on le
sait depuis maintenant des mois et des
mois un certain nombre de pays européens
à tort ou à raison refuse d'accueillir
des migrants la france d'ailleurs
n'était pas la meilleure élève pour
accueillir des migrants on le voit avec
cette histoire de lemos ces dernières
semaines l'allemagne veut bien
accueillir 1500 migrants dont beaucoup
par rapport au premier mais qui est déjà
pas mal
la france accueillir quelques enfants
c'est pour dire oui c'est à dire jean
luc bennahmias quand ursula von der
leyen dit l'ensemble de l'europe doit
faire se doit faire sa part et agir dans
l'unité
ce n'est pas audible pour vous pour tous
les pays européens ce genre de discours
aujourd'hui parce que je n'y crois plus
que doublé en tant que ex députée
européenne pendant dix ans en tant que
membre du conseil économique social
environnemental demande de la commission
européenne européenne et internationale
que vous voulez puis il y avait
désaccord entre pays on le saurait
si les accords notamment sur les
migrants sur les migrations sur l'aide
aux migrants sur l'aide sur l'accueil
ici aussi sur l'aide dans les pays où
d'une sont issus des migrations qui
avaient des accords oraux plaire on le
saurait chimène que le million de autour
de la zone euro il y avait une union
réel la faconde deux pays
cette union n'a malheureusement n'existe
pas alors je comprends que la
commissaire européenne la présidente de
la commission européenne ville
on va essayer on n'est pas obligé d'y
croire si vous voulez et ses terres le
problème c'est que en dehors du fait que
le règlement de dublin n'a rien réglé
donc ça oui d'accord très bien on te
revenir dessus
avenches et un accord à plusieurs pays
européens
malheureusement c'est pas demain la
veille alors on le disait autres
priorités le pacte vers la révolution
numérique et la géopolitique
ces axes là est ce que ce sont les bons
pour redynamiser une europe affaiblie on
le sait notamment par la crise sanitaire
ce surcoût sur la forme ce gars là ne
sont pas forcément mauvais même si moi
je ne quitterai pas le mot numérique au
même niveau que la crise sanitaire et
que le tout tout tout tout le pacte
verges alors qu'ils auraient à mettre en
place
encore une fois je reviens sur ce que
j'aime bien avant quelles sont les
décisions faciles que un certain nombre
de pays européens arrivent à prendre
ensemble
regardez même sur les 750 les canons 750
milliards il a fallu des jours et des
jours
il a fallu une grosse crise et pour
arriver à un accord bancal avec un
corsaire un accord bancal
donc est ce que moi je crois que nos
concitoyens qui ce soit en france ou
ailleurs ne le peuvent plus croire sont
écrasés sur des paroles nouvelles taxes
et les actes là pour l'instant même si
madame brand mel young fait son travail
en tant que président de la commission
les actes on ne les voit pas car oncle
est clairement quand on regarde comment
sont répartis les aides financières
gelées par rapport à la crise sanitaire
ou par surtout par rapport à la rue sadi
carnot par rapport à l'italie mais par
rapport à la france rêve tanéo on voit
bien que les chansons totalement non non
non pas les mêmes niveaux
on voit bien que heureusement tour
d'italie litanie par sans doute et
heureusement parce qu'elle le mérite et
la plus chère sérieusement touché
quelques dizaines de milliards d'euros
mais en ce qui concerne la france on va
plus qu'une et que ce qu'on va toucher 1
soit faux faux faux pour les bureaux
facebook les prothésistes h alors la
présidente a d'ailleurs plaidé pour une
union européenne de la santé
on a constaté que chaque pays finalement
s'est replié sur lui même lors de la
crise alors une horde de la santé cela
passerait par où selon vous est ce que
c'est possible ou pas encore comme sur
les dossiers de la migration par exemple
si on passe à peu près par une volonté
réelle de rolle localisation de
l'intérêt général l'intérêt collectif ça
passerait forcément par une notion de
rupture avec le libéralisme
nos sommes rupture avec cette fausse que
ce serait nier de la concurrence libre
et non faussé la concurrence en oignon
dans une grotte et même dans la zone
euro elle n'est ni ville et alex foncé
tant qu'on saura sont des règles de
libéralisme économique et de libéralisme
financier totalement mort et que j'ai
écouté le reste ce ne seront que des
mots tapio à ce niveau là j'aurai une
politique de santé publique
ça veut dire qu'on est dans une note de
régulation notamment des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques
on est dans un mode de régulation
notamment naissent dans les pratiques de
santé qui sont pour l'instant des
politiques de santé état par état
on l'a vu pendant la crise sanitaire et
pendant le colis dans le voit encore
chaque pays à gérer la crise à sa façon
bombay en affichant son union des
boulettes dont il semblerait que
l'allemagne soit me débrouillais pas
parce qu'elle est privatisée comme on
l'entend non parce qu'elle est nettement
tout est centralisé et qu'elle allie
qualité elle se termine et des
politiques pour but de paralyser
on l'a vu avec la france glg celle que
si quelqu'un comprend la politique
française par rapport aux qu'ovide jour
après jour moi je n'y arrive plein
on voit bien que les régions de santé
nos médecins nos et soignons nos
infirmiers
et enfin toutes les professions de santé
font un boulot magnifique mais dans un
brouillard et dans des contradictions
absolument totale et dans ce cadre là
par rapport à cela est ce que moi je
pense qu' un certain nombre on ne peut
plus gérer l'union européenne comme si
on pouvait gérer à 27
ça n'est plus possible combien de pays
sont capables de se mettre d'accord pour
se dire maintenant ensemble on va
avancer plus vite par rapport au
politique collective merci ai appris
beaucoup
merci beaucoup jean luc bennahmias
d'avoir accepté notre invitation je
rappelle que vous êtes ancien député
européen